did the OG Captain Marvel just take
shots at the MCU from sneaky alien
starfish to Flaming fiddles here are all
the references in Shazam Fury of the
Gods you might have missed before Shazam
and Shazam Fury of the Gods David F
Sandberg directed another feature film
entry in a massive Cinematic Universe
Annabelle creation part of The Conjuring
Universe like the other movies Annabelle
creation focused on the titular doll
controlled by a demon whose only
apparent interest is playing deadly
games with its owners throughout her
three solo movies and her appearance in
the main Conjuring series one of
Annabelle's most enduring qualities is
her uncanny ability to appear out of
nowhere wherever you would least expect
her surprisingly she retains this
ability in both Shazam movies popping up
to add her uniquely terrifying Visage to
the background of a scene in each in the
first Shazam Sandberg chose to sneak
Annabelle into the pawn shop scene at
the start of the movie placing her on a
shelf among the plentiful junk and
making the fact that the two police
officers are locked in the room much
worse in Shazam Fury of the Gods she's
found her way into the pediatrician's
office either by sneaking in or somehow
seeming to the doctor like a toy who
could cheer a child up you understand
I'm a pediatrician
right
as odd as it may sound Annabelle also
has another DC extended Universe Cameo
this time in Aquaman which was directed
by Conjuring Universe Creator James Watt
as funky a name as it can be Shazam
works because it has a deeper meaning as
it's actually an acronym for six
mythological figures from which the hero
draws his power
there's Solomon Hercules Atlas Zeus
Achilles and Mercury although Shazam
himself evidently believes it isn't
Solomon but rather sauroman the white
wizard from The Lord of the Rings the
mistake is understandable though as
another Easter egg demonstrates that
Freeman Billy Batson's superhero manager
is a huge the Lord of the Rings fan
himself at one point in the film Freeman
wears a the Lord of the Rings t-shirt
which may just be a nerdy shirt for a
nerdy dude but perhaps not it's a
fitting depiction specifically the T
features the white Tree of Gondor and
the Seven Stars both of which are
symbols of Ellendale one of the greatest
heroes of all men Ellen Dill was pure of
heart and famous for both height and
handsomeness both traits that Freeman
repeatedly brags about upon assuming his
hero form likewise Shazam name-dropping
sauroman may also be an intentionally
fitting Easter egg
the wizard spent thousands of years
safeguarding men until his resentment
and lust for power caused him to turn on
them and attempt to destroy them all the
exact Arc of the new movie's three
villains Anthea hespera and calypso
for anyone hoping for a Batman cameo in
Shazam Fury of the Gods we have good
news and bad news and Batman is so cool
and I'm just me
to get the bad news out of the way first
no Ben Affleck's Batman never appears in
the movie however the good news is that
another recent bat actor shows up none
other than Diedrich Vader if you don't
know the name that's understandable but
Vader is actually a big bad deal in
recent years he has voiced the Caped
Crusader in shows such as Batman the
Brave and the Bold and Harley Quinn
movies like JLA Adventures trapped in
time and video games like Justice League
Cosmic chaos becoming a go-to bad voice
for Warner Brothers Bader's take on the
character has all the requisite gravel
in depth but the actors comedic
sensibilities hearken back to Adam
West's campy earnestness and charm
Bader's inclusion is a fun Easter egg
for fans of The Wider DC franchise
especially fans of its long celebrated
animated films and series the Easter egg
machine that is Freddie Freeman keeps
running throughout the film this time
delivering a series of references to the
most iconic fantasy role-playing game of
all time Dungeons and Dragons as Freeman
says throughout both movies even
convincing Batson to begin saying it too
he's an expert in all things superhero
and fantasy boasting that when your only
competition is bats and makes sense but
in Shazam theory of the Gods Freeman
even makes the claim to the wizard one
of the oldest most powerful and most
knowledgeable magic users in Earth's
history embarrassingly when it comes
time for Freeman to drop his knowledge
it all comes straight from the player's
handbook while he and The Wizard are
trapped in a magic prison on another
plane Freeman spouts out three ideas for
escape he first suggests giant strength
and gaseous form lastly Freeman asks if
the wizard at least has an Arcane Focus
an item that helps magic users Channel
their powers
some Easter eggs can come across as
unintentional or only referential in a
certain light but some are as clear as
if they were written across a series of
giant fright signs in Shazam theory of
the Gods there is a third option as many
of its Easter eggs are literally written
across a series of giant bright signs
some of the most glaring examples appear
once the daughters of Atlas have planted
the tree of life in downtown
Philadelphia aside from the word Park
which appears numerous times we also see
the tree's roots spread through hedge
Road Lane Spring Garden Street and
finally end up in front of a plant store
its sign reads plants give people and
then tantalizingly cuts off a pretty
fitting phrase given the role of the
Tree of Life in the movie there are a
ton of other non-plant examples as well
after Shazam decides to sacrifice
himself to defeat Calypso in her Dragon
a marquee behind them reads the decision
hurts even better is when Freeman and
Anthea are trapped in a parking
structure with Calypso in the dragon as
a big sign labels the location the owl
Center
if you're a comic book reader especially
a long time one you might know Shazam by
another name Captain Marvel for more
casual fans or those more familiar with
Marvel characters this may sound
confusing but it's true Shazam only
became the character's official name
recently and for the vast majority of
his history he went only by Captain
Marvel this other name never came up in
Shazam but it finally has its day in
Shazam Fury of the Gods when a Philly
citizen proudly proclaims you're the
best Captain Marvel the history of the
name is as convoluted as any in comic
books the character was created back in
the 30s and enjoyed a successful run in
early Comics throughout the 40s however
in a move that will eventually become
superhumanly ironic the characters
publisher Fawcett Comics was sued by DC
for copyright infringement they felt
that Captain Marvel was too similar to
Superman fast forward to the 70s and by
then legal maneuvering has allowed
Marvel to create their own cap in Marvel
and DC to incorporate that old faucet
Comics Captain Marvel into their own
Universe prompting a brand new legal
conflict over the name regardless of the
titles dubious history this Easter egg
and Shazam Fury of the Gods finally gave
Billy Batson the chance to be dubbed
Captain Marvel on the big screen
another name that will likely ring a
bell for fans of DC Comics and likely
not so for more casual fans is Argus the
government agency has been around for
just over a decade in the comics but has
already become somewhat of a Major Force
therein acting as support for super
powered groups like The Justice League
and The Suicide Squad the organization
is even branched out onto the big screen
appearing under the leadership of Amanda
Waller to fund and maintain the
different incarnations of The Suicide
Squad as well as the Justice Society if
you're just watching Shazam Fury of the
Gods however you might have no idea who
these people are even the two famous
members who show up in an Easter egg
that appears during the film's
mid-credits scene Shazam agrees to meet
with two Argus agents who fans of James
Gunn's The Suicide Squad and Peacemaker
will recognize as John economos and
Amelia Harcourt
Economist mother
their presence alone is somewhat of an
Easter egg meant solely for fans of the
DC extended universe as a whole but they
have another goal in meeting Shazam in
fact they formally invite him to join
the Justice Society the super team first
shown on screen in Black Adam that has
been a Mainstay in DC Comics almost
since their very Inception
while economos and Harcourt make the
Trek to their hidden meeting spot with
Shazam they go over their briefing for
the mission they mention that Shazam is
as strong as they get but also immature
and the hero doesn't do anything to
prove the Intel false among his many
childish quips he begins rattling off
better names for the Justice Society one
of which is a delightful and unexpected
Easter egg pointing out that the Justice
Society is a confusing name for a
superhero team when the Justice League
is already a superhero team Shazam
brainstorms a few other ideas most like
the authority Society are bland and as
Shazam himself even admits reminiscent
of a law office name I'm an idiot
however it should be noted that the
authority is a real super team in the DC
extended universe and will soon get its
own big screen adaptation so the
reference is a clear nod to that but
there is one name that does work Shazam
suggests the Avengers Society this is an
apparent reference to Marvel
specifically their famous Justice League
counterpart The Avengers as a few
Avengers themselves have pointed out of
the MCU The Avengers isn't exactly a
great team name itself but that's
irrelevant here the faintest connection
between the two dominant superhero
franchises is enough to make for a
satisfying Easter egg just one of the
many great surprises in Shazam Fury of
the Gods
in DC Comics Star of the Conqueror is a
legend not only because the alien
starfish ended up being the Justice
League's first villain but also because
it gave birth to jarrow the staro in a
jar who became Batman's sidekick and a
totally ludicrous but amazing Justice
League storyline Arc staro has also made
its debut in the DC Universe appearing
in 2021's The Suicide Squad where the
poor creature is eaten alive by rats
staro is gone but not forgotten in the
DCU in Shazam Fury of the Gods the
starfish receives a moment to be
immortalized in the greatest manner as a
letter of the alphabet the scene occurs
early in the film when Shazam lies on a
couch and unpacks his woes The
bespectacled Man Behind the table
reminds him that he's a pediatrician and
not a psychiatrist gesturing to the kids
play area in his office there is an
alphabet chart on the wall with pictures
and who is the image accompanying the
letter s it's starro of course move over
Annabelle this is the best Cameo in the
film
fans familiar with Captain Marvel
Adventures Comics will remember a furry
friend named Taki Tani the
anthropomorphic tiger is a Dapper Ally
of the Marvel family he's the kind of
comic book element that Teeters on the
edge of being almost too ridiculous to
feature in a live-action film shoot even
animated features bring him around as a
boring regular tiger no not again oh you
better believe it
in the first shazam movie David F
Sandberg included a few subtle Easter
eggs as the tip of the hat to Tonic but
he pays even bigger tribute to the fan
favorite character in Shazam Fury of the
Gods when the shazamilee swoops in to
save the people on the bridge Darla
spots a basket of kittens and saves them
first naturally a while later Darla
walks into the house with the cutest
kitten in the world whom the audience
finds out she dubbed Tawny well that's
settled then James Gunn and Peter Safran
better make Tawny a part of the new DCU
or we Riot the Shazam Elise Lair is a
little piece of heaven it's kitted out
like the ultimate Fun Cave complete with
big screens and all the fun that any
child could dream of Lair we got a lair
harbored inside the rock of Eternity is
also a burning violin which appeared in
the first film while this might seem
like a random magical item like Steve
the pen this is a deep cut of shazam's
history that only the Die Hard fans may
remember even director David F Sandberg
remarked on the DC standum podcast that
executive producer Jeff Johns thought
only a few people would understand where
it comes from and its significance to
the lore the burning violin is in
reference to 1946's Captain Marvel
Adventures number 64. and the story
flames of the magic fiddle which sees
ogar's henchmen Nero come in possession
of a violin Ogar bestows it with magical
Flames that keep it burning while Nero
plays and voila there's the origin of
the burning violin that said Captain
Marvel smashes the violin in the comic
and stops it from burning but
considering comic book continuity is
about as stable as a Matchstick no
comments
Mortal Kombat and DC have crossed in the
Video Game World thanks to 2008 fighter
Mortal Kombat vs DC Universe considering
both brands are housed under Warner
Brothers it's easy to imagine them
crossing over flawlessly to other
mediums yet seeing Sub-Zero go to town
on Comic Book Heroes might be a little
uh disarming so fans will have to settle
for the Mortal Kombat Easter egg and
Shazam Fury of the Gods the shazamalese
lair is bursting with all sorts of
surprises however the Mortal Kombat 2
arcade cabinet in particular shows that
the kids not only have taste in video
games but they also know which is the
best in the series also it's a neat
touch to keep that franchise in mind
since the Mortal Kombat 2 movie is in
the early phases of production let's
hope the love is reciprocal and Lord
Raiden wears a Shazam shirt or something
in the movie
[Music]